ça vient frère sur ma vie y'a déjà d'or
l'été en dira qui est semé de maintenant
le besoin et où free c'est oui je kiffe
franchement c'est quoi ça c'est quoi tu
viens direct de marseille je déprime pas
sur une science et le producteur il en
faire quoi si beaucoup de cadeaux sous
la main que dans les pattes on le cuit
fisea pas être tu fait un carton en tout
cas tu vas revenir nous voir c'est ce
père est tout le temps quand tu veux ce
que nous on est avec toi faune et la
flore et graphie en fait les gars c'est
ça une strophe attire pas de
chorégraphie on le fait à l'instinct moi
c'est ce que j'ai vu badass cas merci
est ce que je vous ai dit le pompon et
venez très fort comment sarko tu
t'appelles rien et j'te kiffe aussi
tombé c'est un bon style à régis et le
centre de marseille
ouais ce qui vient de marseille aussi
ouais merci watts tu t'es dit est-ce que
je m'appelle talons noirs quand tout le
monde mais bon c'était un délire je me
tape mais en fait
en fait c'est des gars qui travaillaient
tota ramener des potes dans la rue en
fête en fait ils travaillent avec moi en
lui c'est un chanteur il chante avec ifs
et clippers qui est bien c'est le petit
cousin et moi n'y a pas un gars qui a un
prénom normal manière you tu t'appelles
vraiment clippers walid timo walid il
s'appelle clippers
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'équipe réserve du présent tout
le monde mais juste émission on va te
cacher ses missions et s'occuper de
t-shirts et tout y est les lunettes à
son chant mes frères merci way a été
championne pas la maison du docteur
merci toi bien faire au lycée qui compte
c'est la mascotte mais lui lui fait du
cyclisme ne fait pas de mal tu es venu
en vélo à ses managers lui sur athènes
va vers lui on dirait une comptable de
l'équipe il est venu il y au mieux aux
mines casquette un tee shirt et rémy
laura seras tu vois il a envie de
retrouver sa chemise et son ordinateur
nominé mais avec des coûts des peuples
c'est bourré et mars et sa vigueur et
wat et j'ai vu l'os à un beau gosse qui
perd aussi un seul est quoi mais tu en
gagnes à 2 clippers à la yamaska faire
tu m'aurais dit il ya deux ans avec
avril et même recherché d'heure céret
bravo michel robidoux
merci d'avoir pu vraiment